so how's Santa Marin done anything wrong
this is finland's prime minister at a
party in the summer dancing exuberantly
with old friends this film was supposed
to stay private now it's all over the
internet today another awkward home
video emerged and Marin is facing claims
that her partying has demeaned her job
and even imperiled her country
I didn't have any meetings for example
Saturday or Sunday I had work meetings
on Monday that I
of course handled but we didn't have any
government meetings during that week and
I had time off and and spent it with my
friends and did nothing illegal
her opponents claim misconduct Marin
says she drank alcohol but didn't take
any drugs and has now voluntarily taken
a drugs test to clear her name the
results will not be available for a week
I consider these accusations to be very
serious and for my own legal safeguards
though I think it's very unfair to ask
me to take a drug test today I have
taken a drug test and the results will
be known in about a week's time this is
the son of Marin we're used to seeing
she was the youngest prime minister in
the world when elected nearly three
years ago she's still only 36 but now A
Familiar figure in European politics
habakkas say the backlash is unwarranted
that she's the victim of sexism and
ageism and many will agree that
politicians should be allowed a private
life after all even the most scrutinized
leaders get to dance every now and then
while the likes of Italy's Silvio
Berlusconi have reveled in their
capacity to blend work and pleasure
but this does all come at a time of
tension in Santa Marin's country Finland
is pursuing membership of NATO it held
military exercises earlier this year and
the nation shares a long border and a
painful history with Russia
when we visited a few months ago we
found citizens who were short on trust
and preparing for armed resistance
but Marin is unrepented saying that she
was always in a fit state to lead her
nation and respond to any emergencies
she said people in important jobs should
still be able to sing and dance
Adam Parsons Sky News